okay last one I'm going to show you
before we get back to that original
problem we can start to work with it a
little bit is actually the converse of
this the converse of this now Congress
is a really important idea in
mathematics we don't work all that much
of them specifically but there is one
converse very famous and I think all of
you can help me when you see that well
you see that what's the most famous
theory of a property that jumps to mind
Pythagoras thank you we have trained you
well okay um can someone give me some
lakes on this and then tell me what
Paris isn't okay so if I say Turkey 45
again we've gone for a special you know
obvious one high five tour 13 let's
leave it anyway what's the relationship
here that Pythagoras theorem tells us
okay so 9 plus 16 25 which is not a
coincidence the sum of the squares of
the shorter sides equals the sum of
equals the square of the hypotenuse yes
okay now that's quite a grip system so
we write it like this this is the
standard weight of rider okay now
Pythagoras theorem has a converse right
it has a converse it's the opposite of
this statement what's the opposite of
that statement ok so I could write this
at the moment this is stated so that i
can find what the hypotenuse is like
that's kind of a on the subject of the
formula right i could write it like this
if i wanted in ok and what that would do
is help me find a shorter side however
what this really is is a restatement of
the same idea okay there's something on
which we didn't say up here which we
kind of spot was obvious from the
diagram which is that Pythagoras theorem
is only true in what kind of triangle
writing that's why I put this to you
okay they are therefore the idea is okay
what you know is it's right angle
therefore what you can conclude is
something about the sides and how they
relate to each other okay a converse
takes that and it does it goes
completely in the opposite order so it's
not still talking about signs and
or say okay rather than knowing that the
angle is around and therefore saying
something that size good way to achieve
it goes the other way it says well I can
if you notice something about sides then
you can know there's a right angle there
just that makes sense okay so we use
this we say okay here's a triangle and
it looks a bit wonky or something like
that and we say something like this we
say isn't right angled or not okay and
so you have to test this out you look at
the numbers you square them they like
cool it works therefore even though I
didn't know it before the converse tells
me yes it is right able okay now this is
a big challenge have a look at this this
is saying if you have these parallel
lines but the same base therefore you're
going to have the same area there it is
so what's the converse about don't shout
and out of me I want you there's not
just one right way to say okay but I
think that will be the clearest right
area as I said I thought it would be
helpful if we drew our natural diagram
okay now you'll lose remember I said
okay here number one here's the property
here's the converse okay you'll notice
there a parallel lines on my converse
the parallel lines there could be his
wife think about this right oh this
starts from the idea that there must be
parallel light that's the basis right
just like this starts from the fact that
there's a right angle in the triangle
okay but when you have a look at the
converse the whole point is you don't
know whether there's a right angle there
or not okay and likewise over here your
joy knows a pair of parallel line you
can't put one in and say oh yeah it
looks see here on there okay because you
don't know that yet that's what you
started with over here well it has to be
what you end with over here or something
similar okay so here's the way I'm going
to say it over here I say it up let's
actually put the label so come back to
this first property and let's put some
some long names so if i call these are
these two lines a B and C D and I've got
some areas here a1 a2 a3 okay I guess
the way we would say it over here is
that if you have these parallel lines
right then all the air is equal right a1
a2 a3 okay so from there you can kind of
see all right I should probably start
with something like this this is where I
ended before so the converse are going
to start from there so I'm going to come
over to these two triangles here and I'm
going to imagine if I knew that these
areas were equal right so I guess you
might wear that because you know I
didn't necessarily say have labels on
this you might win if you have a pair of
triangles let's share the same base and
their areas are equal like so okay now
here comes the fun bit right well
therefore what can I say about these
things something about that being
parallel lines i suppose i could do that
but the reason why the parallel lines
are reported is because here to remember
these three blue lights i drew what why
do they matter to our triangles I needed
them there the particular heights to
find the area of these things right so
therefore I know something about the
puppet eagle heights of these two let's
now imagine okay just visualize for me
and maybe more ahead rub this on your
diagram that you actually do have that
power line up there if it really were
there and these areas really are the
same then that means that i should be
able to draw these two guys here now as
it happens both of my triangles are
acute triangles they could be obtuse or
right angle if i wanted them to so these
two lines could have fallen like they're
inside the train goes right now it could
have fallen outside or on an edge at the
moment though these actually have names
this even know what it's called when you
go from one vertex and you go to the
opposite side so that you are at right
angles anyone know that's what starts
with an A
it's called an altitude and altitude so
if you've heard of like our like a play
this wagon some altitude right the idea
is you measure that but perpendicular to
the ground that you're straight up ok so
these altitudes these altitudes if they
really are between the sandwich between
these imaginary parallel lines right
then you've got these two angles in here
or alternatively I suppose you could put
one of these now if you've got two lines
right and you can say it either way that
their corresponding angles are equal or
in this case their Co interior angles
are supplementary then what do you know
about the two lines in parallel I bad
right so in fact the converse of this is
actually not about these guys because
those don't exist on heard a rumor I
don't have any of these lines what I do
have is these two right you see these
guys these altitudes are parallel just
like these are parallel these being
parallel is what makes all of these
altitudes parallel and that's why they
have the same perpendicular height so I
guess I think the way the most succinct
way to say it the Commerce that is is if
you've got two triangles same base same
area okay they're altitudes that's these
perpendicular heights I guess you could
say they're altitudes are parallel
that's probably the nicest cleanest way
to say it like I said there's not but
that's not the only way to say it but on
this certainly implies this parallel
line business just it's nicer because
there aren't the parallel lines there
that I didn't know when there before